le bâtiment est méconnaissable
aujourd'hui moderne sobre recouvert de
bois brûlé selon une technique japonaise
ancestrale plus solides durables avec
des ruines conforter autour l'esplanade
et la promenade rénover la fontaine
remise en service le tout en à peine
quatre mois de travaux pour un budget
d'1 5 million d'euros
le projet a été porté par l'organisation
à but non lucratif culture à bam qui
dépend de la fondation clément ce musée
maintenant est au niveau de musée du 21e
siècle avec des technologies est très
avancé deux audio guides traduction en
anglais en toutes les langues de
l'histoire de saint pierre enrichie par
là la nouvelle collection puisque la dac
avait des objets en stock chez elle et
le musée n'était pas capable de les
recevoir en termes de conservation
c'est tout ça dont il est question donc
des martin qui vont pouvoir ou où est
ouvrir une porte sur leur propre
histoire
par le biais de ce musée à l'intérieur
l'ancienne collection de 432 pièces du
quotidien des pierrotin retrouver après
l'éruption et 28 nouveaux objets issus
des fouilles archéologiques menées à
saint pierre depuis 30 ans prêté par la
direction des affaires culturelles
la mise en scène l'éclairage tout à fait
l'objet d'un soin particulier
objectif offrir une vraie expérience aux
visiteurs à travers le temps de la fin
du 19e siècle à 1933 date de l'ouverture
du musée en passant évidemment par le
drame de l'éruption de la montagne pelée
c'est un vrai parcours en fait qu'on
propose
on arrive dans
dans le musée comme on arrive dans cette
ville par la mer par son port
poursuit le parcours à l'intérieur de la
ville avec les échanges commerciaux avec
sa vie culturelle et on finit par
rentrer jusque dans les maisons dans le
vraiment dans l'intimité des gens
ensuite ben voila je vous laisse
découvrir découvrir notamment cette
pièce au coeur du musée
le mémorial de la catastrophe de 1902
elle avait fait 28 mille morts
grâce au travail de l'association
martiniquaise de recherche sur
l'histoire des familles les noms de sept
mille quarante cinq victimes ont pu être
identifiés ils sont désormais gravés ici
face à la cloche de l'église endommagées
par des nuées dont les températures ont
été estimé entre 450 et 1050 degrés